okay guys y'all [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm back
I'm back I got my iced coffee and you
know this time we're gonna let no
[ __ ] affect anything up okay um got a
lot of [ __ ] hate it oh [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] Oh [ __ ] [ __ ] why is this [ __ ]
like this why are we like in the [ __ ]
middle of bedlam
[ __ ] okay okay y'all [ __ ] [ __ ] I
get a lot of haters and frankly I don't
need it I don't need it what the [ __ ] is
going on here can I get out of here okay
okay [ __ ] be like that you like that
that late pop this sucker that's it you
get with going to the wrong gang okay
all right ladder lad now if you guys
remember last game um some [ __ ] [ __ ]
drawer in my game it just crashed all
[ __ ] okay yeah and I just don't like
that you know I just don't come down
that type of behavior ah batch I here so
she had gone down what is all this
nonsense what's on here cool integra
check
this is like a hidden temple oh oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] hey what the [ __ ] is that
there's like a [ __ ] random dude just
chillin ok ok [ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] that
[ __ ] ok ok what's that [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] Oh [ __ ] housewives okay I'm
gonna take out these guys just for on
and out respect you know I just kill
hope he's not cops or somebody be gone
for a long time
I hear something okay okay
just keep getting better a hedgehog
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] he said next place
I stumbled across something to [ __ ] this
gut
okay looking around getting little snack
hip is you know who's this all right
let's check
the [ __ ] is going on over there well the
good thing is now [ __ ] I can k
something weird is going on oh we got
our [ __ ] keep it what is that that's
this [ __ ] it's yeah that shit's done
okay i guess at layla's love this [ __ ]
did I'm xsi yet can't see [ __ ] okay in
order ranch Christian what I [ __ ]
need skills out skills [ __ ] and I think
that's gonna miss Jill wants pretty
strong okay
he'll out [ __ ] on on here I'm sorry
stuck here the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] I go
over there you gotta be [ __ ] crazy
thank you sir
see me where she does
anything worth anything in here oh
there's a lot of damage your life fire
your [ __ ] eye Oh chef there any money
how can I do I do I'm create now who
feels like all my [ __ ] money okay
okay [ __ ] it I hear this hmm feel like
surround noise is insanely crazy here
always thinking like double direction
coming from so I'm always turning okay
oh [ __ ]
at a Saigon [ __ ] okay this [ __ ] what
is that green [ __ ] on though I should
have gone with the stamina when I say
take helping his buddy up
wow there's so many people here
not [ __ ] I wasn't there like a [ __ ]
ton energy for beer yeah yeah
[ __ ] it's horrifying
okay okay
okay okay just walk it on these walls
cousin who knows what's gonna happen I
hear him Oh [ __ ] a there's up
where is they
all right all right mmm I like sex okay
checkpoint checkpoint stick it a long
way to go so take it easy it was
who else suck that dick raining harder
and harder [ __ ] hi
hmm Oh Johnny likes chachi [ __ ] this I'm
going up here man it is pouring out what
the [ __ ] I need like a sniper rifle ok
can I go like oh we're like backtracking
a bit here who I do not know what the
[ __ ] is going on over there people are
getting her that's for sure please don't
get hurt Oh [ __ ] a huh
please don't see me okay okay
this is [ __ ] insane
all right [ __ ]
hmm and you're gonna ground okay I guy
that's [ __ ] up
that picture over there nice come and I
might forget him oh great hey Chris out
this list
oh I do not feel good about this
Oh [ __ ] a
who [ __ ] a
ok
[ __ ] this [ __ ] guy what is that a
head
oh oh [ __ ] that is one scary [ __ ]
sound okay how soon [ __ ] threw
something at me okay I get let's see
here what do I have what I have higher
that I got [ __ ] um who is this okay how
to help us when you use this
let's say anything else here I like
something explosive I really should make
some [ __ ] volatile that's what I
gotta do knock in a scree dope though
Wow ok hey sorry did okay that's over
here it's over here great like that
because they're an explosive chat see
something this works
who
okay do I have a mouth now if I have
mall totally [ __ ] insane know that I
have liked a shit-ton out who i do not
know today here can I kill this guy
which is this he's like protected except
for the face what is that
hmm this seriously gotta be something
here oh there is
how can a okay what's the plan to get
back up here okay okay here's the master
plan
okay I have to do that it may be a
suicide mission but it's nicer side
Russian come on [ __ ] oh you could do
it you could do it that's disgusting
okay nuys gotta play this real cool
any [ __ ] food Oh what is that
[ __ ] a
look no no God
no no gravity [ __ ] sick now and it's
he had to get my gun back oh [ __ ] this
is going to be [ __ ] awful
I can't [ __ ] walk straight finally
like a key and that Andy snacky piss and
his snacky is
and then I so I can't know you [ __ ] back
here
oh ok isn't that they [ __ ] throughout
me whoo Oh headshot to regret
need to get up there need to get up
there oh I like at a shape why's it so
hard on out leg with Santa was so fast
is that if I guess check it my snacks
out great
okay let's see if i could just survive
here ooh I love up soon okay I still
hear a lot of [ __ ] I'm gonna take this
cuz guarantee there's gonna be some
[ __ ] monstrosity over there
I can't I can't
ah yes yes yes yes just as expected
chef trying to get out of here
having to do this
ok
oh ok
Oh
okay okay i'm running for it
i miss out on this side I'll do it live
whoa that was insane it was worth it
though and I went out like a boss okay I
get see you I'll see you how do I d need
stamina what is this deal more amiable
found it elude whoo I need the stamina
well that good so many people like I was
insane okay now i gotta [ __ ] get back
oh ok I'm sure she's right there ok ok
ok we got this we got this up and plays
thank you and I thank ya show they
[ __ ] lay the [ __ ] open like what the
[ __ ] the [ __ ] is this like a [ __ ] zoo
ok ah i say i clear this room unless you
tuck in ok god bless you water will help
us survive these dark days and better
your good deeds when the end of days
unfortunately there's no good way to get
there I don't know whether you wish to
save ok a meat baby
this is that
that's of course now speak with Joseph
ok you know I think you're gonna add it
there keep it short you know he would
show Thanks browse